i talked to you uh at uh
as we mentioned before months ago um
right after
uh george floyd's uh death
and um well let's be clear we can say
murder now
murder yeah but i talked to you right at
the height of that
and so it feels like i
i'm curious to follow up now that the
trial is over
and derek shelvin's been found guilty
three times
of all of the charges where are you
what's your reaction
to that verdict and the reaction to that
verdict
i mean i think uh so first of all i'm
happy for george floyd's family that
they got a measure of justice
in the civic trial and the criminal
trial so good for them for feeling like
they were heard but
you know if any police in the country
should have been aware
of how they interact with black men
specifically it should be police in that
area
but dante wright was killed right then
right after george floyd right after
shovel was found guilty so i think a lot
of people
have been in the position uh because of
the work i do because of the first
episode of united change which is about
policing
of people asking me to be hopeful or
wanting me to say we can be hopeful
because of that verdict
but you know i'm old enough to remember
rodney king you know like we thought
like oh they got it on film that's going
to change everything
i'm older remember that weird thing we
thought oj being found not guilty was
good you know that weird period of
america so i think that until we
recognize that it's the system of
policing that we have to look at and not
individual acts that we're still going
to see these things repeat themselves
um you know it's interesting because
there's this the movement defund the
police which
is first of all good for you for saying
it out loud a lot of people are afraid
to say it out loud
to say defund the police yeah yeah you
know my
issue with defund the police is when you
look into it you see that there's an
incredible amount of
nuanced terrific ideas to how we can
approach and rethink policing defund the
police
is can lead people in the wrong
direction
which is people think what do you mean
so no police which is
not the concept um uh and
and i think that's something it's almost
educating people what that means
well and maybe there needs to be another
name for it other than defund the place
or i don't know
i mean i think i think of this in the in
the in the big picture way
you have to realize that like from the
first moment
that africans set foot on this country
and got off those boats and we're told
wait what do you want us to do wait for
for free right no i'd like to go back
and then you would realize
there was no going back black people
have had to negotiate for our
for our rights and freedoms and
privileges right and we've had to do it
all sorts of ways whether it's like
what if i sing some negro spirituals
what if i what if i stand up as big
treat the power so black people as a
whole are always
trying to figure out ways to get the
attention of the greater white power
structure
to say can we have our rights and
freedoms so i understand
that people are annoyed with the fun the
police are afraid of it but let's
remember martin luther king jr was
talking about hugs
basically he was talking about like can
we all just get along and he was
assassinated so i think black people are
often in a position of like
how do we get your attention now
famously ice cube said
the police so i feel like the fund is a
little bit less harsh than that
right and it's true i think people get
put off by it so then it becomes my job
as the guy with the tv show
to say let's go through it and talk
about it because you're not going to
google it yourself
so let me do it let me google it for you
you have a uh a chart
yeah maybe you could walk us through the
charts wow this is i've i've never had
physio a high budget but i forgot this
this is by the way this is your eye test
also
exactly so i love that i just told i
just learned you had eye surgery
and uh you yes you're not seeing very
well
you don't you just see a white blob with
some orange stuff at the top i could be
trump for all you know i mean that's so
small they defunded the graphics budget
didn't they yes we did
this is where we are right now we're
like we'll make a chart i was like great
oh okay
this is called defund the show exactly
what i hear uh
but yeah so basically if you look in the
middle of the chart you're saying that's
the police as we currently know them
and the police in many towns get like
anywhere from like 20 percent to like 50
percent of the city's money
right now in oakland right from they get
around 50
but only four to five percent of the
police are for violent crimes right
right and then everything else becomes
about like things that the police
is under their umbrella to do but
they're not actually that good at like
for example
there's a guy in the street who's
yelling and seems like you're having a
mental health episode can you come help
that
can you come help with that generally
and we've seen that happen
over and over again the police come that
person often ends up dead
and what what the [ __ ] is saying there
should be another number to call or when
you call 9-1-1
you should be and you say there's a guy
in the middle of street who's having a
mental health episode then they link you
to a social worker
or somebody else who shows up to help
that guy like for example
richard brooks in atlanta was asleep in
his car somebody called 9-1-1
the police showed up he ended up dead
that should be 9-1-1 can you send an
uber to come pick this guy up and take
him home
and so what the fun the police are
saying there are better ways to handle
public safety than always calling
somebody this is also something that
uh the police would probably be
interested in which is
they don't want to be sent into these
situations uh
and and it's using the wrong
tool for the wrong task there needs to
be a more nuanced full tool chest where
you can say
okay this is someone who has experience
who's not is immediately threatening to
someone who's having an episode and
knows how to
and is actually their whole job is about
de-escalation and connecting with people
not squelching a threat not looking at
everything as a threat i think we think
of police
being like those old batman cartoons
where batman's utility belt had
everything on it right well really
police don't have that much on that
utility belt they have guns they have
they have taser maybe they have a stick
i don't know but they don't it's all
about how to squelch a threat and not
about how to help somebody
when really we need somebody who shows
up with a sandwich on their belt you
know with somebody who can show up with
like
uh like i said i'll give you a ride home
not like somebody's looking at
every individual act as a potential
threat right
although i think the sandwich thing i
would probably be
creating a fuss every day if i knew this
but they were going to send someone with
a sandwich
you know what i mean would i be in the
middle of the street going out
yeah and then i'd be like you got turkey
no not turkey
beef i'll take the corned beef cause
that russian dressing no
call the pastrami cops call the pastrani
cops yes
well but wouldn't that be a great world
if that was the problem i love that idea
conan o'brien is calling the pastrami
cops too
often we have to figure out the city's
pastrami budget is going through the
roof
we have to figure out we have to defund
the pastrami cops
that's the world i want to live